[Music]
anybody here an uh ikea fan i like ikea
yeah i like ikea i like their meatballs
when you go to the showrooms they're
[ __ ] insane like you go like you you
measure it because they tell you oh this
room's only like 95 square feet or some
[ __ ] and you're like damn you guys
packed it good in here i like the prices
man but i hate how everyone got it yeah
yeah that's true because it's affordable
right so then when you go and you're
like i would [ __ ] hook up my room
like this and then you're like but
everyone's gonna have the same thing but
are you a guy that has like a lot of
people over all the time no it's just
for my knowledge when i go to other
people's place i go
that table's from ikea
that light from my oh i know that's from
that those shells are like those [ __ ]
big square cubby shits that's ikea dude
as the 90s would say it's played out
the good thing about everyone oh there
are some over here but the good thing is
you don't put these on camera okay the
good thing about everyone having it
though is that it makes it really easy
to sell because it's like you know you
write down like the item number or like
the mom bed exactly and then it like you
know you get all sorts of people hitting
you up saying like i know what that is i
want that i'll give you a really good
price i didn't even think about the
resale value because i never resell [ __ ]
but the minute they come over your house
and they pick it up everything falls
apart
because the plywood's true
it all breaks down ikea stuff you could
only really move like once
the second time you moved that shit's
[ __ ] moving around that's actually
very true the beds are pretty good
though and affordable i bought a whole
set for like 300 bucks i was using a
ikea bed from like college all the way
to like probably like seven years
a lot of totally last year right yeah
until like yesterday a lot of sex on
that back speaking on those
because it didn't break down
speaking of those showrooms though they
are nice showrooms i always uh i always
try to take a nap in at least because no
one hooks it up to that level you know
it's very thorough people buy a kid they
buy one or two pieces
so it doesn't live up to what it really
could be
that's true so another storm uh snowed
in and stormed in some people in
northern denmark
and those that were
stormed into an ikea they just stayed in
there got a chance to lift some of our
random little fantasies of what it would
be like to actually live at ikea yeah
they just got snowed in uh up to 30
centimeters of snow fell in the city of
auburn leaving at least 25 staff and
customers unable to go home so the group
bedded down in the showroom dined on the
store's food and watched television
that's pretty good 25 people that means
that wasn't that many people there 25
staff and customers but yeah
i think they weren't that many everyone
was like why the [ __ ] would you go
shopping during a storm
just like normal for them maybe
that's denmark i don't know because ikea
is huge man
ikea is big but at the same time like
imagine like you're just randomly stuck
in a giant like warehouse type of spot
and there's no actual walls that sounds
kind of fun actually people probably
like tap tap that showroom like racing
the beds and [ __ ] like that and then
like an old person comes up next year
like
you gotta like [ __ ] get out you know
do you think it becomes squid games
maybe
it's kind of decorated by square games
like would you like troll people like
people are trying to go to sleep like
good night everybody like mom if i could
go to sleep and throw [ __ ] around
you go to the back [ __ ] fuse box and
you shut the lights off for the whole
place
start throwing [ __ ] like little kids
toys start rolling by people's beds
that's how people get killed you know
[Laughter]
crazy
you guys are agitators do you think
anyone tried to [ __ ] in there
mike you sick [ __ ] mike
because i mean he definitely gotta yeah
yeah right there's no way that that's
not like something you're if you're
there with your your significant other
you gotta try you gotta entertain or
some at least the husband's gonna be
like
or even if you're up
for strangers because it's almost like a
uh
cancun like spring break like yolo
yeah i mean it's like what how often are
we gonna be locked up in here yeah might
as well which room would you try to make
love in
the college ones like the [ __ ] in the
kitchen
[Laughter]
would you go to kitchen appliances would
you go in there like where would you go
probably do a showroom for sure though i
don't know i don't think i'll be just
pretty sick you could just arm swipe
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ] decorations
they got there just throw her on the
ground just the real kitchen the one
where they serve the meatballs and stuff
oh yeah the dining hall so you can use
the meatballs
that is one of the things i would do
jesus mike i would just go to ikea just
to get a cheap ass lunch i love [ __ ]
lunch like 5.99 meatballs i don't know
if it's the same price i wonder if they
did like like meatball eating contests
while they were like trapped in you know
what i mean or they had to make rations
dude rations they're already there
they're like
snowed in for one night there's some
over military person is coming in
they're [ __ ] counting meatballs like
that doing the math on each person
we only have enough for one night of
food
there's 25 people i remember when i was
a kid i'd always want to be
uh locked into a mall at night when it
closes like staying there like a
department store like macy's but that
would probably be way better to do in
ikea because there's way more space yeah
or like a target or like a home depot so
you could at least like be crafty and
build some [ __ ] yeah you know spend your
time like if you had to get locked into
some place for like i don't know a year
a year yeah a year
costco
costco we have everything there plus a
lot of food they do have everything
there yeah amazon packing center amazon
packing oh yeah it's like you don't have
to open the box to see what it is
[Laughter]
you're not way off you're having
electronics
yeah but maybe maybe something more like
a showroom versus a fulfillment center
because they might not have like
electrical outlets ready for like
everything to be plugged in and usable
oh yeah right costco costco does like
samples already so you got like at least
a microwave chilling on the side for no
reason yeah and you got mountain bikes
too yeah they got tvs everywhere you can
exercise but do they got beds that's the
most important they got mattresses yeah
they don't have like huge bed frames
they got they got tents in costco you
got to open it and then let the mattress
breathe and come back to life oh yeah
i'm down with a hawaii costco because
they got pokey oh
but i don't know about other pop costco
no way they don't have poker because you
know it's all regional and [ __ ] yeah or
what about like your whole crew like all
of us together
yo what's that one show or movie where
the kid [ __ ] stays over at the mall
like he hides at the um like the
showroom like at a [ __ ] sporting
goods store in the tent and then and
when he [ __ ] you know in the middle
of the night he gets the whole mall to
himself mr mrs smith
no i forgot what show or movie i
remember watching this [ __ ] as a kid
jolie alone in the mall
what are we going to do by hiding in a
tent
and not [ __ ] yeah no way they would
kids movie obviously it was like a tv
show or a [ __ ] guy no i know what
you're talking about because that
inspired me to want to do that yeah but
it would be he stayed in a tent at a
sporting goods store it was at the mall
overnight he got out and he just got to
[ __ ] go ham
sounds like some jonathan taylor thomas
[ __ ] or something
or like richie rich or somebody branch
yeah because i would say like if we
could choose then i'd be like the mall
damn it sounds familiar but then the
mall is like every [ __ ] gate has to
also be up in my imagination it's all up
yeah everything's the whole mall fair
enough you don't have to break into
nothing then then the food's gotta also
be hot and just ready to go there's
employees there employees so it's us and
then the employees too just like this
ikea system everyone's stuck in there
it's just every just we got snowed in
and then the mall is the place because
then we got [ __ ] dave and busters we
got the
khan mongolian barbecue yeah orange
julius cibarro saboro you can watch a
movie in the movie theater auntie anne's
auntie anne's dude
oh what happened oh i i came here in
flip-flops i need shoes you just go to
[ __ ] foot locker and they'll be like
there you go sir you go to claire's
pierce your ears for once
you get a henna tattoo
tattoo balance bracelet
a balance race
move my arm down
yo imagine how dope it would be if a
mall was like a cruise ship or like a
resort where you do an all-inclusive
thing and you get the [ __ ] wristband
and everything in there is free
how much would that have to cost [ __ ]
10 grand a day 10 grand a day you can't
really get your money's worth somebody's
shopping too much it's like being too
drunk they get kicked out
see but you know that apple wouldn't
apply because every time they have deals
like that apple is the one store that
it's like oh we actually don't have
discounts i know man [ __ ] apple
i think they're so much better than us
huh and i still buy this [ __ ] too it's
too good your stuff's again those bougie
[ __ ]
they have the worst black friday deals
it's like 10 off buy 4 000 laptop get a
20 gift card
to spend back at our store
and the lightning cable and that's it no
plug though the lightning cable is like
40 bucks dude these motors have you ever
done apple business
yeah but like i i usually just do uh i
just pretend i'm a student buy it
through a web portal we we used to when
we first set up the jk office we're like
okay cool apple business we're buying
bulk they gave us five percent on
awesome thank you
[Music]
foreign